hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video ihr seht es schon im titel
eingeblendet uns beim musical warum
freue ich mich so ich hab das ganze
letzten schon mal hochgeladen jemand
kleiner ausschnitt hab ich super
hingekriegt aber freundlich will gar
nicht an drumrum reden wir fangen direkt
an mit dem ersten user krediten anhänger
dieses musicals von kirsten hentschel
händler kirsten händler allerdings nicht
verstanden haben
sie wird in dem musical gefragt ob sie
bockhardt mit dieser person abzuhängen
an dem abend in drei stunden am nächsten
tag und dann rast diana personal voll
aus und sagte guck ich finde es
schwierig so was nach zu stellen weil es
halt keinen lied ist bei berlinern
kennen wir irgendwie die lyrics die
bewegung man weiß genau ob er in einer
rede macht man so wenn deine backpfeifen
kriegt man schlägt man sich aber bei
solchen text musical ich sag ich jetzt
mal muss man sich etwas ein bisschen
rein und wenn das gibt mir einen kleinen
moment 2000 jahre später
ich kann es noch immer nicht hielt das
komische ist auch sie setzt halt katz
kurz bevor sie no sagt das muss ich
erstmal selber irgendwie hinkriegen ich
versuche das ganze jetzt mal nach zu
machen als ich wir brauchen erstmal
schwarz weiß jetzt kann es nachmachen
und jetzt setzt sie nämlich schon den
ersten cut bevor solche weiter irgendwie
verwirre ich nehme das jetzt erstmal
auch und ich zeige euch jetzt mal die
musicalversion und danach dann meine
version
ich will mich wirklich selbst logan
gerade aber ich glaube dieses eine
musical ihr euch jetzt schon besser
nachgestellt hat alle musiker ließ aus
dem ersten part den habe ich euch
übrigens oben in der beschreibung
verlinkt das nächste musical ist von max
ich spiele euch das mal ganz kurz ab
super gemacht max das ist echt ein
klasse musicali das einfache bei seinem
musical ist ja die tatsache dass er
nicht im text singt er hat er nicht
irgendwelche kassen effekte drin er
macht einfach nur einen verkrüppelten
rückwärts rollen dings und hat das ganze
auch noch ins loch
das sollte relativ easy sein
an
auch das finde ich habe ich wieder sehr
gut hingekriegt übrigens schreiten wir
bitte in die kommentare eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 8 weil ich in diesem
video acht musical diesen abstellen
werde und wenn ihr euch das video
angeschaut habt könnt ihr dann
entscheiden welches ihr findet was ich
am besten getroffen habe
der vdb das nächste musical von einer
person die ich nicht kenne was mir aber
irgendwie ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das
gefunden habe das wichtigste ist
eigentlich dass ich diese movie
hinkriege mit dem hoch klettern da muss
sich irgendwie wenn sie schießt die
knarre so nehme und aber die kamera so
bewegen dann halt irgendwie so nach
laden oder so und dann am ende noch
dieses bra bra bra mit der hand ging
wieso der camp popdiva madonna kate ich
krieg das einfach nicht gut hin
ich weiß es nicht so gut aber ich es so
schwierig mit diesem scheiß schüssen die
ersten schüsse sind so in
schwierigkeiten
und danach ist es nicht so dass ist
sondern es ist einfach irgendwie okay
ich bin raus wir hatten wir letztes mal
schon im video
da habe ich auch sehr gut hingekriegt
habe ich nicht sehr gut hingekriegt
werde ich auch dieses mal nicht gut
hinkriegen
ok allein dieses komische bauchtanz
dingo ii
dafür muss man tanzen können ich glaub
jetzt könnte ich tanzen
ich habe nicht mal angefangen aber ich
gebe jetzt schon auf ok halber
geschwindigkeit ist drin nicht vorbei
ich habe irgendwas übersteuert ich muss
übrigens erst mal wieder kamera hier auf
diese position so ein bisschen nämlich
das ganze jahr hin kriege ich werde das
jetzt übrigens in meinem teil dafür auch
aufteilen
ich glaube es war gut heute ich habe
keine ahnung wie ich den zweiten teil
irgendwie hinkriegen soll also es sieht
jetzt nicht ultra schwer ausmacht
irgendwie den hier und an denen hier und
dann irgendwie so und keine ahnung was
aber ich kann mir das nicht mehr
es war komplette scheiße ich zeige es
euch bei einer gegenüberstellung
curry
ich habe es leider nicht im schnitt
gesehen aber ich glaube ich kann soviel
sagen dass ich den ersten teil relativ
guten abgestellt haben im zweiten teil
komplett beschissen
wir machen weiter das musical über citis
nachstellen werde ist dieses ziel jetzt
nämlich eine katze von ihrem frauchen
irgendwie geknuddelt und dazu gibt es im
text und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ich hole mir wieder meinen katzen und
dunkel was ich sonst auch immer am start
habe nämlich simba der ist super bowl
für so was ich musste kämen dafür wieder
hier in die hand nehmen
ich glaube das war relativ gut oder
well support
das gerade war so fucking sind wir nach
zu stellen ich hab's noch nicht gestimmt
und kann euch jetzt nicht sagen ob ich
gut oder schlecht hingekriegt habe für
mich war es einfach so ich konnte die
kamera nehmen und konnte mit meinem kopf
auf den bildschirm gucken ob die lyrics
genau gucken mal wird weiter
nein
das soll ich noch machen
ich weiß nicht wie du solche musicals
empfohlen werden wirklich überhaupt
nichts gegen die leute die sowas machen
aber ich finde sowas einfach schlichtweg
unkreativ da sind leute eben ihr handy
und drehen sich im kreis
ich versuche mal nach zu machen
ich glaube das war gut
also ich glaube dass konnte waren
schlechter stellen
ok stopp ich weiß dass viele jetzt
denken resolute free agent mal dass ein
mensch und er ist cool ich probiere das
ganze jetzt first reihe nach zu stellen
also habt es nicht vorher geübt
für den ersten versuch das nachzustellen
also nach einmal angucken
das war schon recht gut oder das nächste
musical die das lasche werde ist dieses
hier ja das ist dieser cup dingsbums mit
einer katze
das war's noch nicht mit dem video meine
damen und herren weil das was ich hier
jetzt gerade aufnehme und wie ich jetzt
geradezu ich spreche ist vier stunden
nachdem ich das eigentliche video
aufgenommen habe gerade entstanden
ich hoffe ihr könnt ein bisschen vor wie
auf jeden fall gerade mit dem stück
fertig geworden und hat mir einfach
gedacht ich sei viel zu wenig danke für
euren ganzen support und so wird es
einfach in den letzten tagen richtig
krass aufgefallen dass viele neue leute
dazu gestoßen sind hier und meinen
content feiern natürlich gibt es auch
noch ein paar hater aber die gezählten
leute einfach mal ganz dick danke sagen
für euren support also dass ihr wirklich
alles immer kommentiert dass ihr immer
nett seid und dass ihr mich trotzdem
feiert auch wenn ich jetzt so ein
bisschen was neues ausprobieren mit dem
content und so wenn ich das mal mache
mache ich das ja sonst mal so dass ich
das am ende des videos mache allerdings
habe ich ja neuerdings diese neue audio
funktionen drin dass ich bei videos
sagen ihr könnt nicht abonnieren und da
ist neues video verlinkt und deswegen
geht das jetzt nicht mehr weil man kann
das auto in den letzten 20 sekunden
eines videos machen ist aber auch egal
ich wollte wirklich einmal nur danke
sagen bevor jetzt auto auf nehme also
cohep lady outro das was hier vor dem
video meiner lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat freue ich mich über einen
daumen hoch und jeder schreibt mir jetzt
mal entweder eine zahl in die kommentare
von 18 oder einfach einfacher einfach
einfacher gesehen schreibt einfach so
was rein wie beispielsweise lukas liga
oder sowas wie kirsten häntzschel
händchen hält einfach das rein schreiben
von dem musical i wo ihr denkt dass ich
am besten abgestellt habe super coolen
hier oben sind legal ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr
einfach meinen kanal abonnieren und ihr
findet hier ein video verlinkt das ist
nämlich musicals nachstellt 1 also der
vorgänger von diesen teil auf jeden fall
auch nach hause schicken wenn ihr da
bock drauf habt dann
mach das einfach und ich mache mir jetzt
mit pizza